so here University of Chicago econ
professor career torn apart after
criticizing defund the police and the
basic premise here is that this
professor in good standing tweeted that
he did not think defunding the police
was such a hot idea and he was
investigated and to the credit of the
University of Chicago they decided there
was nothing racist about what he had
said but he would be my point a this is
the University of Chicago this is the
last stand right this is the college
that has done the best at protecting
freedom of expression it's not like they
laugh its principles have been the
beacon of hope there's a very standard
this is the gold standard yes but they
didn't laugh off the claim that he was
racist for believing that defunding the
police was a bad idea and said so
publicly they looked into it right so
that's where we are a tweet which suck
and you just put it up one more time
right at the bottom of what's on the
screen here it shows the egregious
perhaps firing worthy tweet I just grow
up can you show it to us on the main
screen because we can't see that very at
the bottom too bad he wrote too bad but
hashtag black lives matter per its core
organization at black lives matter just
torpedoed itself with its full-fledged
support of defund the police so yeah
it's it's jaw-dropping because that's it
so do you fund the police right it's
obviously an ambiguous hashtag but I
would argue deliberately so and many
people will tell you oh we really do
mean completely defund the police and
the police I would say if you are
advocating anything like ending the
police without creating the society in
which the police are no longer necessary
the advance right you are let's give you
a thousand stupid points right you're a
thousand stupid if you think that's a
good idea right now let's take it one
step farther
not only do you believe that defunding
the police completely in advance of
fixing society is a good idea but you
think that anybody who is skeptical of
that idea is inherently racist okay now
are you a hundred thousand stupid if you
believe that I mean it seems to me it's
this is not how you don't really talk no
it's not how I normally talk but this
idea is so bad I mean as we are now
discovering in the top tears right yeah
the chop-chop-chop three shootings one
of them three now fatal yes it has three
shootings I mean completely predictable
this is in a six square block declared
nation-state if it's owned that's what a
week and a half old three shootings
already right three shooting is already
and you know we see a that the people
organizing this zone having a freaking
clue how things work so there's one
piece of video in which they are begging
paramedics to come deal with one of the
shooting victims but there's another
piece of video in which they're actually
assuring the cops out and driving them
off of the same incident and you know
the fact is a you're not autonomous
you're not providing your own medical
services and police services you're
doing some other thing then you're
demanding services which yes I do
believe that somebody who's been shot
deserves to have you know they're still
in Seattle is this the zone is a fiction
but I don't expect the paramedics to go
in the autonomy of the zone is a fiction
yes they are presumably they're not
growing their own food I mean I
understand there's probably Gardens at
the moment but yeah you know they're
they're using city water they're getting
food from outside they're getting
medical services from outside you know
the money that they're not there they're
nowhere close to autonomous and you know
more power to a group that would
actually try to do this but they clearly
have no idea what it actually takes and
what number of systems they're relying
on right what number of systems they're
relying on and of course at the moment
that you need the paramedics there's not
even a thought in their minds like oh
wait we're autonomous you know yes like
well we're gonna drive the police out
you know berate the paramedics for not
coming in and not put
two and two together yeah right that's
perfectly absurd and then we on the
outside who exist in a world of
linguistic traps in which we are all
trying to assure everyone that we Harbor
you know no wrong think are suffering
from a totally insane presentation
really depends what channel you listen
to if you're watching you know the sort
of CNN half of the universe you're
getting a picture of the the I can
barely say chop with a straight face
given that it doesn't even
linguistically add up yeah occupied
protests I yeah it's an occupation and a
protest maybe but yeah you don't occupy
a protest but in any case yeah if you're
paying attention to the sort of
left-leaning mainstream press or
nominally left-leaning mainstream press
you get this picture of it's a festival
it's like a party it's a barbecue it's
you know the next version of Burning Man
yeah all hunky-dory if you pay attention
to the sort of left the right leaning
side you get a completely opposite
picture it's like people are being shot
there's all kinds of skullduggery and
shakedowns and all of this
[Music]